on en vient maintenant ces nouvelles
frappes sur Kiev ce matin la capitale
ukrainienne et ses environs visés par
des attaques au drone des appareils de
fabrication iranienne selon le président
Zelinski le chef de l'État la sur le
système de défense entier aérien a été
abattu la totale battu la totalité des
engins Gulliver crack et sur place pour
France 24
vous voyez derrière moi l'un des deux
bâtiments dans Kiev qui ont été
endommagés mercredi matin par les
frappes russes nous sommes à 8 km et
demi du centre-ville mais le bruit des
explosions s'est fait entendre dans
toute la capitale
ukrainienne ce matin peu de temps après
que les sirènes avaient retenti juste
après 6h du matin c'était aussi bien sûr
le bruit des missiles solaires tiré par
les systèmes de défense anti-aériens
ukrainienne qui disent ce matin avoir
abattu 13 drones au-dessus de Kiev et sa
région pas de blessés à signaler pour le
moment par les autorités le bâtiment
derrière moi n'est pas un immeuble
résidentiel c'est un bâtiment
administratif c'était à un moment où les
gens n'étaient pas encore arrivés au
travail mais juste autour à ma gauche et
à ma droite il y a des immeubles
d'appartement ou les vitres ont été
brisées les travaux sont déjà en cours
pour mettre en place du plastique ou du
carton des travaux bien sûr très urgent
vu la température qu'il fait